[MUSIC PLAYING]
FENG LU: Hi, welcome
to Cloud on Air--
Webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Feng Lu, and I'm a
software engineer at Google.
Today I will be talking
about Cloud Composer.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
Now let's get started.
So today I plan to cover
the following topics.
I will start by giving
an overview of Composer.
Next, we'll talk
about how to use
Composer, followed by a demo.
And I will wrap up
my talk with pointers
on how to get you started.
So before we start, like,
what's Cloud Composer?
What kind of problems are
we trying to solve here?
In many cases, we find a need
to run something, run a task
or run certain operations,
at a predefined interval,
or in response to
an actual input.
Now, we not only find
that in our workplace.
Sometimes it happens
in your life as well.
It's just the case that
you don't realize that.
For example, you may have
an alarm that wakes you
up every day at
8:00 AM, or you may
want to send an email
every Thursday night.
So for a task as
simple as that, Cron,
which is a utility in
Unix operating system,
might be sufficient
for your need.
Sometimes when your task gets
a little bit complicated--
for example, you may
have a few tasks,
and there are some
dependencies among those tasks.
In this slide, I have an
example in the middle.
Imagine that you have Google
App Engine application, which
is constantly dumping logs
into the Google Cloud Storage
bucket.
And every once in
a while, you want
to run a Dataflow job that
processes and cleans up those
logs and saves
them to BigQuery so
that you can run useful
analytics from the user data.
Even a task where--
a workflow as simple
as what I just
described, if you think about
how you want to implement that,
it's actually a lot of work.
You need to make sure you
understand the APIs that talk
to the various Cloud services.
You need to make sure you
have the right authorization
and account in
place, and not even
to mention that you have
to worry about failures.
There could be service
failures, network failures.
So at the end of
day, you realize
that you spend a lot of
time not actually focusing
on your workflow, but rather
on all the infrastructures
that run your workflow.
I probably would
not even attempt
to try to use Cron to run
a sharded machine learning
pipeline.
That's just too complicated.
So we believe that it should
be easy to create, schedule,
and monitor workflows that work
inside and outside of Google
Cloud Platform.
With that mission in mind,
we introduce Cloud Composer
service.
In a nutshell, Cloud Composer is
really a managed Apache Airflow
service that makes workflow
creation, management
powerful, consistent,
and easy for you.
We start the Cloud
Composer project
with a number of
product goals in mind.
We wanted to have a
comprehensive integration
with a lot of Cloud services.
So like I mentioned earlier, as
a workflow author or a workflow
user, you don't have
to worry about talking
to the various Cloud services.
So we do want to provide
high-level abstractions so
that it make it easier for
you to start using other Cloud
services.
We also don't want to limit your
workflow to just be task-only.
We want it to be the case that
it's just as easy as for you
to start jobs
elsewhere-- for example,
in another cloud provider,
or even on Prime--
as starting a job in
Google Cloud Platform.
We want to make the
workflow specification,
or the definition of the
workflow, easier for you
as well.
So hence we choose
the popular and easy
to use language Python for
you to write your workflow
definition.
And finally, we want
to have open-source
in the core of Cloud Composer
so that your workflow is
agnostic to where
it gets executed.
You can transparently move your
workflow from GCP to on-prem,
to another cloud provider.
So next, I'm going to talk
about some of the key features
as well as some of the
design decisions we
have made to fulfill the product
goals I just articulated.
We really try to--
so in Composer, we
provide a list of key features.
And those key
features are centered
around three main schemes--
simplicity, security, and
production monitoring.
I will explain each one in turn.
So for simplicity, we
have convenient tools
like Cloud SDK or
Cloud Console for you
to interact and manage
Composer services.
We also make it easy for you
to manage your workflow DAGs.
We make it easy for
you to manage plug-ins.
And then, moving on
to the security bit,
we use Cloud IAM to manage all
the credentials, permissions,
and access policies.
Composer also comes together
with built-in support
for Cloud
Identity-Aware Proxy so
that your workflow-monitoring
[INAUDIBLE]
web server is secured
and protected.
And finally, we realize the--
we also integrate
with Stackdriver
to provide you with logging
and monitoring metrics
so that you can
build a dashboard
to visualize the internal
state of with your workflows
and also alert you when your
workflow is not running well.
I'm going to discuss a key
concept in Cloud Composer
that's called environment.
So what is a
Composer environment?
It's nothing more than
just a managed deployment
of Apache Airflow.
Inside a single GSW
project, you could
have multiple environments.
And those environments
are perfectly isolated
from each other.
In each environment, we
provide you with Cloud storage,
where you can manage your
DAG sources or your workflow
sources.
And you also have the stack.
We also provide you individual
workflow web servers
for you to access your
workflow status pertaining
to their specific environment.
Finally, we have
Stackdriver, that
provides convenient
tools for you
to navigate through
multiple environments.
And the last thing
I want to mention,
that each environment is
protected by Cloud IAM.
So you can config
permissions individually
for each environment.
Now we're going to talk about
some of the design decisions.
Earlier, I mentioned
that Composer
has open-source in its core.
And you know, there are a lot
of open-source orchestration
solutions.
Why did we decide
on Apache Airflow?
For those of you
who are not very
familiar with Apache Airflow,
here's a quick history on it.
It was originally from Airbnb.
And that project has donated
to Apache Software Foundation.
It's in incubation stage now,
but it's soon to graduate.
We chose Apache Airflow
for a number of benefits.
Number one, it's open-source.
It's based on
Python, easy to use.
It has a lot of [INAUDIBLE]
interface today.
You know, you have web server.
It has a very nice web server,
convenient command-line tools.
It also has an experimental
API server for you
to interact with the
service programmatically.
One thing I want to
highlight for Apache Airflow
is that it has a very powerful
and flexible scheduling
and dependency mechanisms.
So pretty much, you
can encode a lot
of different dependency
relationships among your tasks
in a workflow.
It has a lot of
community-contributed
connectors.
For example, you have
connectors to AWS, Google Cloud
Platform, interfaces to a
lot of databases as well.
And last thing is the
Apache Airflow community
is very active.
There are lots of
commits, many developers.
Overall, it's a fairly
active community.
On the downside,
I think, probably,
when the project got started, it
wasn't really focused a lot on,
for example, a production setup,
permission management, logging,
debugging, and all that stuff.
For example, in
Apache Airflow, we
don't really
mandate, say, how you
want to run your web server, how
would you scale your machines
when the workload gets more.
So those happen to be the things
that Google Cloud Platform is
good at.
So in Cloud Composer, we provide
infrastructure scalability.
We have security built in with
Cloud IAP as well as Cloud IAM.
We make it really easy
for you to deploy DAGs.
And we have Stackdriver
login and monitoring for you
to make sure your Airflow
environment's running well.
I also wanted to mention,
another point is that we
don't--
Google doesn't intend to just
fork a copy of Apache Airflow
and just make a
service ourselves.
We want to work together
with the community,
and together, enhance and
improve Apache Airflow.
So in the past, we
have worked together
with the community to contribute
the Kubernetes executor back
to the Airflow community.
As I mentioned,
Composer/Airflow comes together
with a number of
built-in services.
I'm not going to read
out all the services.
Some of the notable
ones are BigQuery, GCS,
[? pop-ups, ?] data flow.
So as a Composer user, you
don't have to worry about,
how do I interact
with those services?
Instead, Composer or Airflow
provides nice operators for you
to start interacting
with those services
without worrying about
authentication and API details.
I'm also going to give you
a little bit of details
on architectures, how
we build Composer.
So if you look at the
overview of the architecture,
it has two projects.
One is the customer project.
And the other is
the tenant project.
So customer project
is really the things
you see on a daily
basis when you're
logged into your Cloud console,
where you use [INAUDIBLE] SDK.
So those other
projects owned by you.
And you have full admin
control over those projects.
On the other side,
there's tenant project.
Tenant project, again, is also
a Google Cloud Platform project.
But those projects are
owned by the service.
In this case, it's the
Cloud Composer service.
We decided to host some
services in tenant project
for enhanced security
and better isolation.
We'll come to that
point in a minute.
In this setup, we
tried to set up
in a way that sort of reflects
the popular Airflow Plus
[? pseudo ?] executor config.
Given the microservice nature
of the framework of Airflow,
our implementation also sort
of reflects that structure.
For example, there will be
a Airflow scheduler service.
There's an Airflow worker.
There's also an
Airflow web server.
So Airflow scheduler
and Airflow worker,
we host both inside
Kubernetes engines
in the customer project.
And then for Airflow web
server, as I mentioned,
we hosted that web
server in tenant project
so we can have integrated and
built-in support for cloud IAP
protection.
Instead of configuring
IAP yourself,
Cloud Composer does
that it for you.
And you manage that
access to your web server
using Composer permissions.
In addition, you
probably have also
noticed that we have put
the Airflow database inside
of tenant project as well.
The reason behind it is that
we believe since Airflow stores
connection, which is the
access credentials in Airflow
database.
So we want to make sure
that that database is
only accessible to a
very narrow set of users
with service accounts.
In our default setup,
the Airflow database
is only accessible to
the service account
that you used to run
the Kubernetes engine.
By the way, during
Composer creation,
you have the choice
to specify which
service account you want to use
to run your Kubernetes engine.
So let's move back to
the customer project.
We have [INAUDIBLE],, which
is the [INAUDIBLE] backend
for messaging distribution.
And we have the SQL proxy
for accessing the database.
Moving down the graph a
little bit, we see that DAGs,
plugins, and logs.
Those folders are all
created inside per project,
per environment, Google
Cloud Storage bucket.
Again, Composer manages the
distribution of the DAGs
to your various
Airflow services so you
don't have to worry
about how do you
make sure your Airflow
service is going
to sync to the latest stacks--
likewise for plugins.
In Airflow, the
plugins are for you
to write customized operators.
Here, Composer would also take
care of plugin integration
into Airflow services.
And finally, at the
left side of bottom,
you see the logs, the
Stackdriver Logging.
In addition to Airflow logs,
the scheduler and worker
logs also saved in Stackdriver.
We do that so that it provides
a centralized place for you
to navigate through all
the logs, but in addition,
also try to make streaming logs
really fast and really on time
for you.
So here's a quick recap.
We have just talked
about what Composer
is, the problems
Composer tries to solve,
some of our initial
product goals,
some of the Composer
notable features,
and our design decisions.
Next, we're going to
talk about how can we
use Composer to actually
author and schedule a workflow?
So to create and access
Composer environments,
there are three ways.
You could use Cloud SDK, which
is our command line tool.
Or you can use the cloud
console, which is the UI tool.
And finally, you can also
interact with the service
programatically using our API.
There is no
additional setup step
you need to do when start
to work on workflows.
Once the composing
environment is created,
the next thing you
need to do is to focus
on your workflow developments.
In the context of
Apache Airflow,
it's also called DAG, which
stands for Direct Acyclic
Graph.
What that means is
in your workflow,
you shouldn't
really have cycles.
So here's a quick example about
how typical workflow with DAG
would look like.
Imagine that you have some files
that is hosted on-prem in HDFS.
And then periodically, you
want to copy that to file--
say for example, if you
detect the new files
and then you want to copy
that files to GCS bucket.
And once the data
is available in GCS,
you may want to
launch a BigQuery job
and then try to process
the data and then
get some useful
insights from the data.
And once the insights
are available,
you may want to send out
that data to a Slack channel.
So that could be some
of the typical workflow
you will run inside Composer.
There are about five steps
really for you to write
an Airflow DAG or workflow.
We summarize that
into five steps--
import, write arguments,
do your DAG setup,
lay down the various tasks, and
then encode task dependencies.
So this is the standard part.
Before you write
your DAG or workflow,
you import all of the
necessary libraries.
In this case, you want to make
sure you important the DAGs,
the operators from Airflow.
And if you have specific or
customized trigger rules,
you also want to import
that from Airflow as well.
And once you have
that import in place,
you could start to
construct your arguments.
So Airflow DAG has a default
DAG arguments section,
which for you to specify
[INAUDIBLE] arguments that
apply to all tasks in the DAG.
So for example, you can specify
when you want your DAG to get
started, whether you
want to receive email
when there's a DAG failure, and
if a task fails, how many times
you want to retry that task.
What's the delay between
consecutive retries?
So this ties back to our earlier
discussion on writing workflows
yourself.
I mean, in this Cron
plus scripting example,
you have to worry all
those retries yourself.
And you have to actually built
in your own email operator
inside so that you make
sure you get notification
when a DAG or a workflow fails.
Here, in Composer
or in Airflow, you
get all that being
provided for you already.
The only thing you need to do
is write your configuration
and leave all the details
to Composer or Airflow.
So after that, if you have
additional global variables
that you plan to use
in your DAG, again,
you can list them here.
So for example, here we
have the GitHub table.
We have the output file
and the BQ dataset names.
After that, you start
to set up your DAG
by giving the DAG a
name, define an interval
that how often a DAG should
be triggered and executed.
And then of course,
you past the default
args, arguments to the DAG.
There's one thing I
want to highlight here,
is that make sure that your
schedule interval is set here.
You can't set a schedule
interval in a default args.
It won't work there.
So that's the one thing
I want to point out
when you write your DAGs.
The next step is basically
to lay down all the tasks
you need in this workflow.
So in this specific
example, we have two tasks.
One is about running
out Bigquery task.
The other one is publishing
a Bigquery output to GCS.
As you can imagine, you can
have as many tasks as you want.
Airflow also allows you to
programmatically generate
a task--
for example, write a
user for loop to generate
and array of tasks.
So all this is entirely
possible in Airflow.
And finally, you specify
the dependency or orderings
among your task.
In this case, what
this line says,
I want to run my
BigQuery first before I
expose the result
to GCS, which makes
a lot of sense in this case.
Once you have everything
together, then
you're good to go.
So now we're going to give a
[INAUDIBLE] demo using Composer
so that we tie all the
concepts we have discussed.
Now back to the demo.
I, for the sake of
the presentation,
try to save some time,
I have pre-created
a composing environment.
So if you click on one of the
environments, I call it like,
in this case, it's
called a composer demo-.
It has a number of tabs.
And then you got to see
all the details that
pertain to a specified
composing environment.
I'm going to quickly go
over some of the properties.
Don't worry if you can read
all the text on the screen.
For example, you have
an environment name.
You have a location,
whether this environment
is running in US central,
Europe, or West one.
You've got a chance to
specify service account.
There's also a specific
Composer version
that you are running
in this environment--
now some details related
to the worker node,
which we use to run Airflow
scheduler and Airflow workers--
[INAUDIBLE] machine type,
the disk size, and et cetera.
There are two things that you
want to pay special attention.
One is called DAGs folder.
So if we click through
that DAGs folder,
that leads you to a place where
all DAGs should be staged.
To deploy a DAG is as
simple as I could drop
a file in this DAGs folder.
And likewise, you realize that
there's another one that's
called Airflow Web UI.
If you click that web
UI, that leads you
to the familiar Airflow
web UI interface.
You would be able to access all
workflow-related information as
well as some of
the configuration
and the admin panel.
In order to access this
Airflow web server,
you need to make sure that
you have the right permission.
So I skipped the
part [INAUDIBLE]
[? login, ?] it probably
won't prompt me for login.
But if you are going
to create one yourself
and try it offline, you
probably will see a login window
prompting you for
email and password.
So that's the way
how CLOUD IAP works.
You check that the user
has a write permission
before it allows you to
open the Airflow web UI.
So as I mentioned,
deploying a DAG,
it's as simple as
dropping a file here.
So let me get that started.
So I'm going to
upload a DAG file.
This DAG file, in fact,
it's called Quick Start,
is, in fact, the Quick
Start guide in our cloud
documentation website.
So I just upload this one.
It's done.
It takes a few minutes for
Airflow to pick up the DAG
and to start execution.
While waiting for Airflow to
pick up the DAGs, and then I
also want to give you some
quick overview on some
of the other
configurations you're
going to be able to
do in Cloud Composer.
We allowed you to update Airflow
configuration in real time.
So for example, if you want to
hide the configuration admin
panel, you could just make a
change to say, hey, web server,
expose configure to
[? force. ?] After that change,
your configuration will be
hidden from the login users.
We also allowed you to
install PyPI dependencies.
Imagine that your
workflow requires, say,
select client to be installed
or [INAUDIBLE] to be installed.
You could simply just use
the PyPI package management
feature in Composer and
then specify the0 packages
you want to install.
So for example, you
could add a package.
You could add a slackclient.
And then you can also specify
option of which [INAUDIBLE]..
So that's all you need to do.
After that, you click Submit.
That's all you need to do to
get to the dependency installed
for you.
Now, let's come back
to the Airflow web UI.
Let's do a refresh, because
Airflow web server doesn't
do refresh by itself.
Now we go.
We see the Quick Start
start to appear in a web UI.
Because, as we
mentioned earlier,
Airflow is on
microservice architecture,
so you have a web
server component.
It also has a scheduler
component. [? Notes ?]
component are not
perfectly synced.
So sometimes if you see things
like DAGs being recognized
in one place and
not the other place,
just gave it a few
more minutes or just do
a few more refreshes.
And hopefully, you'll see
the DAGs being shown soon.
There we go.
So click through the DAGs.
It has different views for you
to navigate through your DAG
structure.
There's a graph
view so that you see
that we have three tasks, like
create a dataproc cluster,
run a simple
[? work con ?] example,
and the delete the
dataproc cluster.
There's different views,
like graph view, tree view.
And you will also be
able to see the details--
for example, how long does
it take for a particular task
to complete?
In many cases, if you
want to inspect the code,
you could also
see the code here.
So let's go back to the web UI.
Right now, we are
in a stage of trying
to create a dataproc cluster.
So we can go to
view the logs, see
what has been specified there.
This is essentially says,
hey, right now this task
has started.
Some of you may wonder,
given that Airflow already
has workflow or task
logs, why you still
want to provide work logs
or logs in Stackdriver?
Here's one difference.
If you go to Stackdriver
Logging, go to Composer demo,
then go to Airflow
workers, you actually
see a lot of more things here.
The reason between [? site ?]
differently, Airflow tries
to upload logs periodically.
So it comes together where
depends on some internal cause.
So you don't always
see the latest logs.
But with Stackdriver
Logging in Composer,
you would be able to see all the
logs that happen in real time.
Sometimes if you happen to
have a task that takes a while
to complete-- a few minutes
or in some extreme case,
maybe an hour to finish--
and [? this, ?] you want to be
able to see those logs earlier.
So Stackdriver logs would
be the place where you could
see all the streaming logs.
Let's go back.
As we can see, the created
dataproc cluster task is done.
Now we move to the
work [? cons ?] task.
One thing you
notice that Airflow
works as a UI to highlight the
different stage of the task.
For example, you get a dark
green when a task is done,
relatively light green when
a task is still active.
I will give you a
few more minutes
to let the workflow to complete.
But as you can see,
once the task is done,
you will to be able to see a
lot more details in the log.
So those contains all the logs
that [INAUDIBLE] by Airflow.
I want to say that those
logs are very helpful.
Sometimes when you
have a task failure,
you have no idea
what's happening.
Those logs provides the
initial place for you
to do investigation.
A lot of times, the failures or
exceptions will be logged here.
There are other views for
you to manage your task.
They provide task views,
which you see tasks
from all workflows running
in this environment.
You would also be able to
see the active DAG runs.
So you have DAG
view, task view--
depends on your need.
They're very flexible
for you to navigate
through your workflows.
Sometimes you can also
create a manual run in case,
for example, if you
don't want to wait
until the scheduled interval,
it is also possible for you
to just create a
manual run yourself.
Just put a DAG ID, give it a
run ID, and then click Save.
That it will start a manual
run of the same workflow.
Now we have seen that
all the tasks have
been successfully completed.
And then you also have the
[? summary ?] [? tasks ?] here
as well, like how long does
it for a task to complete?
So that that's the
end of the demo.
We're going to switch
back to the slides.
So here's a quick
recap on the demo.
We just illustrated, we
just showed you how to--
we skipped the part of creating
a Composer environment.
There's a reason why.
I'm going to discuss
that and also
give you different
ways-- in this case,
we primarily focus on
Cloud Console for you
to access the
Composer environment.
But it is also
possible to interact
with Composer environment using
Cloud SDK or even the API.
Next, we're showing you
how to upload a DAG--
as simple as just drag and
drop a file into that GCS
[INAUDIBLE].
And then we have walked
you through the various UI
features comes together with
Apache Airflow web server.
And finally, we also
talked about why
we want to use DAG drivers
to exam Composer logs.
So you don't have to
wait until a task is
done so you can
see streaming logs
coming in as the task executes.
I'm going to wrap up the webinar
by giving you some pointers
to get you started.
Given Composer is a manager
of Apache Airflow service,
so all Apache
Airflow [? confabs ?]
would apply in Composer.
We recommend to you to go
over the Apache Airflow
documentations and also some
of the Start Guide there.
They have very good
documentation explaining
the concepts of DAGs.
They also give you a lot
of tutorials as well.
Specifically, the Cloud
Composer documentation website
will also give you
all the details
about how you interact with
the Composer environment,
how do you create
an environment,
how do you manage
your environment,
and how would you
access your environment?
In addition, it will also give
you price information how would
you monitor your
Composer environment,
how to interact with Stackdriver
overflows-- excuse me--
Logging and monitoring.
And finally, the team is
trying to add more DAG examples
in Composer.
So we have a few
examples in the GitHub.
but the team plans
to add more there.
So that will be the end
of the presentation.
Stay tuned for the live Q&A.
We'll be back in a few minutes.
Welcome back to the Q&A session.
So I'm going to read out
the questions posted here.
So the first question
is about how long
does it take to create
my Composer environment?
We have received some customer
feedback saying, hey, seems
to take a long time for me to
create my Composer environment.
Sometimes it can be
15 or even 20 minutes.
The reason here is that
together with Composer, we also
host the Airflow web server
inside a Google App Engine.
And for those of you
who have used Google App
Engine in the past,
you probably know
that it takes about 15
minutes to get your App Engine
app created, initialized,
and stabilized.
So that's the reason
why creating a composing
environment takes
15 to 20 minutes.
Now the second
question is about,
how do I get to
email notifications
when the workflow fails?
If you still recall, when
we worked through the DAG
structure, in one
section, there's
a configuration option in
default [INAUDIBLE] section,
where you can say,
hey, email on failure
or receive email notification.
By the way, you also need to
put an email address there.
So given there some limitations
in Google Cloud platform,
mainly from spam and a security
perspective, that you can use
SMTP directly when running
your application in GKE.
So instead, in this case,
we use [? centigrade ?]
for all that email
notifications.
To config email for using
[? centigrade ?] service,
really, you only need to supply
an email in centigrade API key
as well as a form address.
And then those can be configured
as part of your Composer
environment variables.
Our documentation website
has a lot more details
about what kind of
environment variables
should you put into your
Composer environment
to get an email working for you.
The next question is about
which Apache Airflow versions
does Composer support?
That's a very good question.
So right now, Composer
only supports Airflow 1.9.
It's on a roadmap to support
multiple versions of Apache
Airflow.
So for example, at
environment creation time,
you could specify, hey, I want
to use Airflow 1.8 or Airflow
1.10.
So those multi-version support
is on our roadmap for sure.
But right now, only
1.9 is supported.
The next question
is, do you have
any suggestion on
migrating on-prem Airflow
setup to Composer?
So ideally, given Composer as a
manage Apache Airflow solution,
your DAG should work
transparently across on-prem
and GCP and vice versa.
Sometimes we do notice
that if your DAGs has
a reference to the local
environment-- for example,
if you try to refer to
local [? fault ?] systems
or other nonstandard
Airflow operators,
those might be a
friction for you.
So you want to make sure
those got corrected.
And then if you make sure that
your workflow doesn't refer
to anything in your
local environment,
then in addition of copying
your DAGs from your on-prem
to Composer, the other
thing you need to concern
will be the outflow
database migration.
If it's the same
Airflow version,
the migration can be as easy
as export your database data
and import that
again in Composer.
Or if you don't want to
retain all the history,
you could also
selectively just copy over
the connections or variable
configurations you need.
Next question is,
can I orchestrate
at a hybrid environment
with Composer?
Yes, that's totally possible.
So you could have task
running on [? prem ?]
as long as you make sure
that, for example, you
have the right network
connection set up in place.
Composer or Airflow is really
agnostic to the type of task
that gets executed.
The next question
is very similar.
Can I orchestrate a multi-core
environment with Composer.
Yes-- as I mentioned
earlier, they are connectors
not only to GCP, but there are
also connectors to AWS or Agile
or other cloud providers
in Apache Airflow.
So really, the only
thing you need to do here
is to make sure you have
the credentials config
as connections in
Airflow or Composer.
And afterwards, when you try
to instantiate an operator
to a non-cloud
provider, make sure you
refer to the right
connection name string.
So that's all you need to do.
The last question
is about, oh, I
have a lot of tasks
in my workflow.
How does a composer handle
Airflow worker scaling?
Very good question-- for
now, the composer API service
does allow you to manually
scale the number of workers.
So for example, if you
realize that, oh, suddenly you
have a burst of tasks where
you need to [? stand ?]
maybe 1,000 tasks or
machine is running
short of machine resource.
What do you need to do is just
log in to the Cloud Console
where [? your ?] [? class ?]
[? SDK ?] to upsize the number
of worker nodes you have.
It will automatically
manage the scaling for you,
as well as making sure that
Airflow configurations are
updated accordingly to
match your cluster size.
Notably, there are
a few scalability
or parallelism
configuration options
related to the number of
workers you could have.
So those will be taken
care of by Composer.
So you don't have to
worry about that at all.
In addition, auto scaling is
also on our official roadmap.
So we may have auto
scaling support sometime.
As a result, you don't have
to worry about scaling at all.
So that will be the
end of the Q&A session.
Thanks a lot for staying
to listen to the webinar
and definitely stay in tune
for next Tuesday's webinars.